gut dann beginnen wir mit der heutigen
sitzung ich sage nochmal was zur app zum
digitalen begleiter rahmen dieser
veranstaltung
wie sie wissen habe ich eine app
erstellt die für lukas tab und sie
können die sich kostenlos herunterladen
wird es sehr empfehlen da sie das tun
weil sie nämlich über diese app
regelmäßige information bekommen
zum ablauf dieses seminares nicht nur
diese szene sind alle meine drei in
diesem semester angebotenen seminare
wenn sie jetzt mal hier auf diese diese
grafik schauen diese zweite abbildung
dann sehen sie hier unter dem zweiten
menüpunkt was ist zeitnah also wenn sie
jetzt hier das menü rein klappen dann
haben sie hier die übersicht und wenn
sie dann da drauf klicken auf zb was es
zeit dann sehen sie alle einträge die
bisher online gegangen sind zu diesem
thema
als sie sehen dann zum beispiel die
zusammenfassung der letzten sitzung die
jetzt auch herumgeht sie sehen darin die
leitfragen für die heutige sitzung sie
können sich darüber den text für die
heutige sitzung herunterladen und sogar
die folien die sie gerade hier sehen die
sind mittlerweile auch schon in der app
drin und wenn sie mal ein bisschen noch
sich andere sachen anschauen wollen dann
können sie einfach zum blick werfen auf
zum beispiel meine seminar über
determinismus freiheit das hat die farbe
orange das thema was zeit ist glaube ich
blau gehalten so orientierung mit diesen
symbolen hier und da gibt es noch
kausalität seminar das ist glaube ich
rot sie können sich also sehr schnell
gleich auf dem laufenden halten
da hab ich fragen wer sich die app
heruntergeladen hat gab es probleme
bisschen vielleicht so ein bisschen aber
sonst okay okay aber sie meine push
notification bekommen meine platz mal
vibriert und das kam so eine nachricht
von mir nicht bei wem wir einfach mal
melden wer was bekommen hat mit push
notification eine person hinten nicht
seltsam egal sein sie froh dann vibriert
nicht so häufig schickte nicht häufiger
was war jedenfalls können sie sich das
so jetzt einfach mal anschauen
ja ja die stelle ich noch rein genau
also die hatte ich jetzt noch nicht
einstellen können aber die sitzung
werden aufgenommen sie können die dann
demnächst nach ich schickte aber auch
wieder so eine nachricht rum über diese
und tally weijl okay jetzt haben wir
auch gesagt es gibt es ein filmangebot
ich schreibe ihm da jetzt demnächst
heute oder morgen eine e-mail wo jetzt
genau der ort ist für dieses für diesen
kinofilm am freitag
dieser film hersteller will mir das noch
verraten gut also schauen sie regelmäßig
ins e-mail-postfach letzten im nächsten
tagen dann hatten wir jetzt uns in
diesem seminar in der letzten sitzung
ganz allgemeine gedanken gemacht zurzeit
problematik und wir sind auf folgende
fragen gekommen das sind natürlich nicht
alle fragen die man bezüglich der zeit
stellen kann
aber es sind vielleicht die wichtigsten
also ist zeit etwas kontinuierliches bis
ins unendliche hinein immer weiter auf
teilt wahres auf spaltbares also das gar
nicht eine ein zeitpunkt mehr existiert
sondern dass mit diesem zeitpunkt immer
wieder analysieren können und wieder und
wieder und wieder immer wieder
aufspalten also das zeigen die gar keine
wirkliche ausdehnung hat als punkt als
konkrete entsteht oder ist sie
tatsächlich etwas diskretes alle liegt
sie in kleinsten einheiten vorher gibt's
so was wie eine langzeit zum beispiel
sagen die physiker jedenfalls aber wir
wollen einfach mal argumentieren was
spricht dafür was spricht dagegen und
hier ist immanuel kant der gewährsmann
der hat hierzu sehr interessante
überlegung angestellt
zweite frage die wir uns überlegt haben
ist gibt es zeit ohne subjekte mit
selbstbewusstsein zeit ist immer was
subjektiver muss es deswegen auch etwas
sein was nur die illusion ist was gar
nicht existiert oder existiert seit eben
als etwas subjektives das ist die frage
die wir uns heute bei augustinus ganz
vorn
stellen werden aber natürlich auch bei
rocksong und bei anderen denkern die wir
noch behandelt werden spielte auch die
subjektivität immer eine große rolle
dann kann es überhaupt gegenstände ohne
zeit geben sind zahlen oder
mathematische sachverhalte zum beispiel
der satz des pythagoras ein kandidat
dafür
wenn es ihn überhaupt gibt wenn er
existiert existierte also gibt es
entitäten die nicht derzeit unterliegen
und ein möglicher eine mögliche entität
ist natürlich gott da kommen wir heute
drauf bei abbyy augustinus augustinus
hat gott ist nicht in der zeit weil er
die zeit erschaffen hat dann kann er gar
nicht in der zeit existieren das ist
also ein bisschen heute auch das thema
wie verhalten sich zeit und raum
zueinander sind sie voneinander abhängig
und falls ja wie genau hier ist immanuel
kant wieder ein interessanter philosoph
aber auch aristoteles den wie der
nächsten sitzung behandelt werden
wir sind also nicht mehr ganz korrekt
chronologisch vorgehen weil wie sie alle
wissen aristoteles natürlich vor
augustinus geboren ist also einem
vorchristlichen und augustinus ist im
nach christlichen zeitalter geboren aber
ich denke von der thematik her passte
besser die zweite sitzung auch
aristoteles fragt sich wie zeit und
bewegung die kinesis miteinander
zusammenhängen
das hat man uns ja auch schon belegt
eine zeit scheint irgendwie mit bewegung
zusammen zeigen wenn es jetzt nichts
gibt was sich bewegt oder bewegen könnte
gäbe es dann zeit fragezeichen also die
zeit sehen wir immer an der
veränderungen die veränderung ist
natürlich auch eine form der bewegung
könnte man sagen das ist eine spannende
frage immanuel kant unterscheide
zwischen dem äußeren und im inneren sinn
der äußere sinn ist er für den raum
zuständig der innere sinnes das
zeitempfinden und kann glück dafür
argumentieren dass wir uns an eine zeit
denken könnten inneren sind ohne den
äußeren sinn also rein das immer
subjektive bewusstsein
das ist möglich im verhältnis zum haben
wie verhält sich zeit zum phänomen der
geschichte es ist dasselbe jetzt
zeitgleich geschichte zeitliche verläufe
sind die geschichtliche ereignisse oder
ist geschichte noch was besonderes an
der zeit könnte man sagen dass
geschichte zeit ist die in freiheit
gestaltet ist also setzt geschichte
nicht nur subjekte voraus wie es die
zeit tot offensichtlich also zeit ohne
subjektivität ist nicht jedenfalls die
volle zeit die wir haben
die wir den begriff wir haben also
natürlich gab es auch am zeitliche
ereignisse jetzt ein physikalischer
hinsicht veränderung jedenfalls wie
aristoteles sagen würde bevor es
überhaupt subjekte gab die zeit
bewusstsein entwickeln konnten das ist
klar dinosaurier über die hat natürlich
so zeit finden oder subjektives
empfinden im schwachen sinne phänomenal
das bewusstsein aber bevor es überhaupt
lebewesen gehabt sagen
kurz nach dem urknall da geht natürlich
die physik davon aus dass ist da zeit
gab das ist klar aber wie sieht es aus
mit der geschichte als geschichte
scheint nicht nur seit bewusstsein
vorauszusetzen sondern geschichte
scheint auch noch freiheit
vorauszusetzen also zeit sinnvoll mit
bedeutung zu erfüllen
das eine zeit eine bedeutung hat und
dass eine zeit verschiedentlich
gewichtet werden kann
das scheint mir ein spezifikum die
geschichtlichkeit es sein dass man zeit
in epochen gliedert dass man überhaupt
zeit unterteilt zeitabschnitte epochen
dass man so was machen kann das scheint
für geschichte zu sprechen man spricht
jetzt auch von einer erdgeschichte von
einer kosmologischen geschichte stellt
sich die frage ist das eine richtige
sinnvolle verwendung von geschichte oder
ist es nicht nur in abgeleiteten
analogen singe
diese fragen werden wir bei schelling
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling
nachdem dieses
da sie hier hinter ihm benannt ist
immanent seiner philosophie berne
wie verhalten sich zeit und freiheit
zueinander
das ist eine frage die bei heiliger auch
so ein bisschen anklingt obwohl er nicht
den freiheitsbegriff so stark ins
zentrum stellt aber da spielt so
unterschwellig eine große rolle dann
gibt es natürlich immanuel kant noch der
dafür dazu was gesagt hat und diesen
neueren denker anderen fertig kocht er
noch lebt er noch gar nicht so alt ist
er jetzt in heidelberg professor ist mit
dem wollen wir uns auch noch am ende
befassen und dann haben wir gesagt wir
reservieren ganz für die letzte sitzung
noch eine phase für modernere
entwicklung in der physik und schauen ob
wir da auch noch schlau draus werden
können jedenfalls sollten wir auch noch
vielleicht auch in der letzten sitzung
nur diese fragen nach der richtung
derzeit behandeln das ist jetzt auch bei
augustinus die frage also kommt die zeit
auf uns zu also bleiben wir als objekte
fixiert an einem ort und die zeit läuft
auf uns zu als die zukunft kommt wie der
name schon sagt auf uns zu und passiert
uns und geben die vergangenheit oder
fahren wir mit der zeit sozusagen nach
vorne also das ist es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten wie man sich die bewegung
gericht und derzeit vorstellen kann
jedenfalls während beide modelle jetzt
ein modell wo es nach vorne geht und
jetzt kann man sich fragen kann sie
nicht auch rückwärts laufen kann man
nicht in die wand könnte man logisch
gesehen eine zeitreise unternehmen die
vergangenheit oder ist das per se
ausgeschlossen
es gibt da verschiedene dilemmata also
wenn man was man natürlich nie tun
sollte einen engen verwandten
dann in der vergangenheit eben ich sage
jetzt mal außer gefecht setzen würde so
dass der nicht in der lage wäre dafür zu
sorgen dass man selbst entspringen
konnte dann würde man ja eigentlich gar
nicht existieren können wenn man das
verhindert hätte oder überlegen sie
würden verhindern dass sich ihre eltern
kennenlernen sagen jetzt einfach mal so
harmlos dass die sich nicht begegnet es
gibt auch filme wo dann jemand die
vergangenheit reist und ein date hinein
platzt seiner eltern und das also
vermasselt und dann kommen die nicht
zusammen und man selbst konnte nicht
entstehen aber dennoch existiert man ja
insofern man in der vergangenheit ist
und das ist ein bisschen paradox wir
wollen einfach diese möglichkeit
magische orte wo sie sich vielleicht
doch eine möglichkeit gibt es ein
kleines logisches logische perspektive
dass man zeit reisen vielleicht noch
unternehmen könnte
so viel zu den fragen die wir uns
gestellt hatten und die kann man es auch
noch stellen eine psychologische frage
stellung also ein die vom ersten letzten
handelt also gibt es einen absoluten
anfang derzeit gibt es ein absolutes
ende der zeit diese frage stellt auch
immanuel kant dann stellt sich die frage
nach dem ersten anfang auch im sinne der
kausalität also bekannt denkt zeit und
kausalität sehring er fragt nach der
ersten ursachen und das hängt natürlich
auch mit dem anfang der zeit zusammen
okay das sind also unsere fragen so weit
und jetzt gehen wir über zu unserem
heutigen denker augustinus
in allgemeinverständlicher bei der
ersten sitzung
dabei unterscheiden sie sich
wir werden auch jetzt schon bei
augustinus sehen dass zeit immer so
einen subjektiven charakter hat das am
erlebnis objekt der zeit orientiert ist
aber das ist davon noch in anderen
zeitbegriff gibt den sie vielleicht
kosmisch sitzen meinen mit dem sie gut
ist dass in dem kosmischen meint also
die letztendlich zum absoluten begriff
der zeit der nicht gebunden ist an das
subjekt das zeitempfinden es gibt immer
so 2 und bei mctaggart das ist ein
englischsprachiger philosoph das 19 und
20 jahrhunderts der hat verschiedene
zeitreihen unterschieden eine bar eine
beere monetäre und eine dieser reihe ist
auf das objekt gerichtet das ist also
diese subjektive zeitempfinden und es
gibt eine andere reihe die ist er so
diese was sie vielleicht mit diesem
kosmischen dieser absoluten zeigen die
die sind nur in relationen es ist früher
spät
also es gibt diese unterscheidung
zwischen subjektiver zeit und absoluter
zeit mussten wir brauchen irgendwie
beides also zeit ohne zeitempfinden
seine subjektivität ist für den menschen
jedenfalls sehr schwer vorstellbar
und diesen punkt der subjektivität
derzeit den bespricht ganz prominent
augustinus in seinem schrift in seiner
schrift die heißt bekenntnisse die
konfessionen
ich sage jetzt noch mal ein bisschen was
zum hintergrund von augustinus finden
sie alles natürlich auch auf der app
wenn sie da mal reingehen als als wiki
eintrag also praktisch im vierten und
fünften nachchristlichen jahrhundert
gelebt und ist einer der vier großen
kirchenväter kirchenlehre
es sollte man also wissen ja lebte im
übergang von antike zum frühmittelalter
also spätantike könnte man auch sagen
hannah arendt hat in dem entdecker des
willens genannt er hat sehr viel über
die menschliche freiheit gesagt über gut
und böse die man hier wahnsinn gegenpol
die man nicht her hatten damals
behauptet es gibt eine gute eine böse
macht die existieren sozusagen absolut
fast schon als pole und augustinus hat
sich gegen diese magnetische auffassung
von gut und böse
die wand und hat die these vertreten
dass gut und böse letztendlich nicht
eine separate mächte sind
das würde ja auch die monotheistischen
weltbild bisschen widersprechen
das ist schon ab gegen gott geben bösen
gott oder sowas das hat also augustinus
stark kritisiert diese auffassung und
hat stattdessen dieser guten böse
beziehen sich immer auf unsere freiheit
als darf das feuer des subjekts des
einzelnen durch die entscheidung genau
und dann ist auch noch ganz wichtig also
gut und böse spielen jetzt mit blick auf
die zeit nicht so eine große rolle
was aber wichtig ist es die
subjektivität also hier also es könnte
man sagen denn nicht nur der der
erfinder des willens begriffe den deckel
des willens sondern er ist auch ein ganz
prominenter denker der subjektivität und
wir finden bei ihm zum beispiel in
konfessionen mit bekenntnissen auf die
ich auch noch gleich zu sprechen kommt
bei den finden wir argumente die auf
eine ganz ähnliche weise wie diejenigen
von rené descartes den sie anerkenne die
frage nach der gewissheit der eigenen
existenz zu klären versuchen
also augoustinos sagt wenn ich suche
oder frage dann bin ich ja schon
existiert ja schon überhaupt suchen zu
können sagt dann dass die subjektivität
besteht bereits im suchen das ist diese
selbst reflexivität also augustinus wird
der wille und das objekt selbst reflexen
das ist also der denke dass selbst das
selbstbewusstsein der selbstreflexion
und also das ist wichtig und man muss
auch noch dazu sagen er hat ein sehr
interessanter begriff des geistes
entwickelt und er steht mit diesem
begriff des geistes oder der
subjektivität und der seele dem inner
psychischen das selbstbewusstsein zu tun
hat in einer gewissen kritischen distanz
zu platon also platon ist für augustinus
ein wichtiger bezugspunkt
und man muss aber dazu sagen dass er
dann im christlichen sinne sind diese
christlichen theologie verschiedene
platonische elemente modifiziert hat vor
allem das den geist mit begriff
anbelangt was die die verschiedenen
momente der wirklichkeit betrifft das
höchste sein
da gibt es die geist seele des menschen
und dann die niedere welt des werdens
das ist natürlich auch bekannt von
platon die welt der erscheinung die
bloße fuß ist das was wird und was
entsteht und die welt der ideen die die
über allem schwebt und man könnte jetzt
ein bisschen zugespitzt sagen während
plattform so diese zwei reiche lehre hat
also so übersinnliches das sind ideen
die uhr bilder das absolute und die
abbilder die bloße welte erscheinungen
wie man es auch im sonnen gleichnis
kennt hat also nur zwei bereiche der
wirklichkeit kennt diesen starken
dualismus hat versucht augustinus noch
einen dritten bereich zu analysieren und
das ist dieser zwischen bereich zwischen
bereich zwischen dem absoluten den ideen
den ewigen vielleicht auch zeitlosen
bereich und dem los nach platon damit
irdischen vergänglichen reicht dieser
zwischenbereich den augustiner sie ganz
prominent analysiert das ist eben der
bereich der subjektivität gästebereich
unsere freiheit das ist die schnittmenge
ich kann es auch mal kurz hin zeichnen
nach platon und ganz unten wo es dunkel
wird
hier ist die vergängliche welt obwohl
die bloße abbilder ideen sie natürlich
die uhr bilder und hier sind die
abbilder und bei plattform gibt es
diesen starken tourismus
und
augustinus versucht hier das subjekt
objekt selbstbewusstsein und freiheit
beziehungsweise den willen auch noch als
eine art von zwischenbereich wieder zur
geltung kommen zu lassen
das soll jetzt nicht heißen dass nicht
bei platon sich auch seelen teile finden
platten wie sie alle wissen kennt drei
sälen teile der die ram analysiert mit
der staatslehre also der untersten teil
der wird dem leerstand zugeordnet also
den bauernstand dass es eher so der
triebhafte seelen teil
dann gibt es so einen teil der ihr so
mutig der mut hafte der tumor idee ist
also der das ist so ein prototyp des
willens als der mut habt also auch der
der serien teil der aktivierbaren ist
denkbar ist der so ein bisschen noch
schon näher an der vernunft ist das ist
also der mut des endes der zweiten teil
von unten gesehen
oder gibt es auch den obersten
serienteil es ist das logon als den
vernünftigen sie enthalten vernunft
zähle also grad an kennt schon so eine
dreiteilung der seele
aber kennt kein eigentlichen willens
begriff und den eigentlichen subjekt
begriffen kennt er auch nicht so sehr
man könnte sagen gut dass wirklicher
selbst muss das objekt ist die vernunft
seele ist logistik konnten aber
letztendlich auseinandergerissen durch
diese 30 in time und aristoteles
versucht augustinus versucht diese diese
drei sälen teilen auch in die stärkere
einheit zu bringen
durch sein begriff des geistes wenn sie
sich dafür interessieren zu dem geist
begriff augustinus noch ein bisschen
mehr lesen wollen diesen zwischenbereich
hier bezeichnet die nicht mal ein
bisschen markiere
dann schauen sie einfach auch mal auf
die app unter diesem menüpunkt über
augustinus sondern finden sie da im link
zu systemen geist begriff bei ihm ich
habe meinem seminar gegeben vor einem
semester der zwei semestern sogar wo ich
mich damit aus genauer auseinander
gesetzt habe genau also das ist wichtig
also augustinus ist einerseits durch
platon beeinflusst aber er modifiziert
seine die platonische theorie recht
stark und wir wollen deswegen jetzt
heute uns ein paar fragen stellen
ich sagte schon einem christlichen
kontext wie genau ist der theologische
kontext beschaffen innerhalb dessen
augustinus sich die frage nach dem wesen
der zeit zu finden
also die ganzen ersten seiten dieses
textes den sie bekommen haben ist
eigentlich so eine theologische
ansprache theologische anrede kommt
erstmal nicht so viel von der zeit vor
das ist also ganz wichtig ganz typisch
augustinus dass immer der theologische
kontexten rolle spielt dann kann man
sich vor ein argumentiert augustinus
überhaupt finden sich darin argumente
oder ist es nur eine behauptung dann
kann sich durchaus fragen wie der text
funktioniert wie gesagt dieser text
stammt aus den bekenntnissen das ist
also ganz wichtig ist verwendet wie
diese personalplanung ich habe das getan
und er wendet sich an alle gegenüber an
gott du diese also fast schon dialogisch
situation das ist auch was besonderes
dann kann man sie jetzt ganz konkret
fragen welchen und theologischer status
die zeit hat also wie sie es einst mäßig
existiert ist sie etwas wurde jetzt sie
nichts
diese frage wirft augustins ganz
prominent auch dann kann man sich fragen
und da ist augustinus auch eine der
ersten das so diese frage aufwirft wie
sich vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
zueinander verhalten also die
dimensionen die ekstasen derzeit und
dann kann man sich fragen wie die zeit
mit dem subjekt derzeit erfahrung beim
zusammenhängt also ist sie eine bloße
vorstellung wo sie es empfinden los
schlechten sinne subjektiv oder hat sie
nicht doch in ihrer subjektivität eine
eigenständige realität
das ist die spannende frage und für alle
mit dieser frage worden und sollte
befassen wie die zeit obwohl sie ohnehin
der g-ba subjektiv ist nach augustinus
dennoch eine eigene realität haben kann
ok haben sie da haben sie noch
ergänzende fragen die sich ihm ergeben
hatten bei der lektüre dieses textes gab
es probleme mit den text zu öffnen
konnten sie in alle erhalten und sich
anschauen da sie können text auch
kopieren sie können in den text hinein
gehen
der text ist mit ocr verfahren behandelt
worden
sie können also wirklich komplett machen
und sich ein eigenes exzerpt daraus
erstellen
ok wenn sie jetzt keine weiteren fragen
mehr haben gehen wir direkt in den text
über und ich hatte ihn ja schon gesagt
wie wir das machen
ich habe jetzt mal die für mich in
meinen augen zentralen passagen einfach
auf folien kopiert und wir gehen die
jetzt drei nach durch und diskutiert
darüber wenn sie jetzt von sich aus
sagen ich hab dann noch eine textstelle
bei mir angestrichen in meinem ausdruck
und die würde ich gerne behandelt können
sie gerne das sagen und dann unternehmer
die noch nicht auf aber ich habe ein
paar vorschläge von zitaten hier an die
wand zu projizieren
jetzt vor und wir lesen jetzt einfach
mal gemeinsam als beziehungsweise ich
gehe es jetzt einfach mal vor dass auf
seite 23 es waren die also ungefähr
glaube ich dreißig seiten text die sie
von mir bekommen hatten
natal stolz da habe ich mal fragen wer
von ihnen lateinkenntnisse hat einfach
mal melden
also die hälfte das doch erfreulich und
selbst wenn sie keine lateinkenntnisse
haben ist das nicht schlimm weil sie
sehr gut parallel lesen können die
wichtigsten begriffe verstehen sie auch
wenn sie keinen lateinkenntnisse haben
wir wollen also immer auch bei solchen
fremdsprachlichen texten hat auch bei
aristoteles in einem nächsten sitzung
heute bei augustinus durchaus mal so ein
bisschen in das lateinische original
hineinschauen und das sollten sie auch
für die ausarbeitung
also werden sie jetzt eine hausarbeit zu
beabsichtigen als beabsichtigen dann
sollten sie aber darauf kommen nochmal
genauer zu sprechen wenn sie jetzt eine
passage zitieren und analysieren immer
auch die wichtigsten begriffe und
klammern in den dateien
original angeben das ist nicht so
schwierig wir gehen da noch genauer
darauf ein dass sie immer so einbezug
sie müssen nicht das gesamte lateinische
zitate bringen aber wichtige begriffe
sollten sie schon in der originalsprache
dann in klammern hinter dem jeweils
deutschen besetzten begriff anführen ok
also jetzt sagt hier augustinus in
seinen bekenntnissen auf seite 23 und
zum text
er sagt es gab also keine zeit in der du
noch nichts geschaffen hat ist weil du
selbst ist war es der die zeit
geschaffen hat keine zeit ist ewig wie
du weil du ihm sein verhasst wenn sie
aber zurzeit im sein verharrte wäre sie
keine zeit
was ist denn überhaupt sein könnte das
leicht und kurz erklären wer kann etwas
übersieht zur sprache bringen oder sie
auch noch in gedanken erfassen was habe
ist uns im reden vertrauter und sicher
gegenwärtig als die zeit und wir
verstehen das wort durchaus wenn wir es
aussprechen wir verstehen es auch wenn
wir es hören falls ein anderes
ausspricht ist natürlich gott als
gegenüber geologische situation oder
seine anrede situation was sagt er jetzt
ist jetzt gott selbst in der zeit oder
warum nicht wenn das nicht ist was
würden sie sagen
wie versteht jetzt augustinus hier die
zeitliche existenz gottes
hier verhält sich gut zum vermieter
zeigen
das macht
stell dir vor derzeit ganz genau in der
zeit vor gut ist guter punkt genau also
diese frage was vor der zeit war
oder gab es eine zeit vor der zeit ist
jetzt gar nicht so sehr für augustinus
der punkt sondern wie sie völlig richtig
sagen es geht also um so ein causales
verhältnis und verhältnisse der
ursächlichkeit und hier ist auch ein
weiterer wichtiger begriff der begriff
der ewigkeit
also und der begriff des seins also der
das seinen demnach augustinus gott
verharrt ist ewig im sinne der
letztendlich die gewöhnliche vorstellung
von zeit transportiert jetzt hatten sie
sich noch genau
[Musik]
der eigentlich in der zeit nicht in der
zeit ist
genau guter punkt also sie haben völlig
zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass wir
eigentlich nicht sagen können gott ist
vor der zeit warum ich will sie sagen
vor ist ein zeitliches sind präposition
eine zeitliche präposition im
landläufigen sinn es gibt es noch einen
sinn von vor genau wie es gibt auch
diese bedeutung des deutschen wortes vor
oder pre lateinisch was logischen senats
oder auch in ordnung logischen sinne
jemand eine person ist einer anderen
person vorgeordnet oder diese
gedankliche operation diese von einer
ableitung eine logische ableitung kommt
vor dieser operation
es ist jetzt nicht ein zeitliches in
zeitlichen sinne zu verstehen hat es
gibt man kann verschiedene dimensionen
oder also verschiedene formen und dieses
voraus analysiert also diesen rein
zeitlichen sind ja auf den trips nicht
ist es geht wohl ihr im sinne der
kausalität also was war funktioniert des
entstehens oder der möglichkeit der
existenz der bedingung eines bedingung
verhältnisses zuerst und dieses zuerst
natürlich auch im schnitt der rangfolge
was ist wichtiger ich denke das ist ein
wichtiger hinweis wenn wir dieses vor
hier untersuchen haben sie sonst noch
gedanken zu diesem kontext also
interessanter aspekt erstmal über die
göttliche zeit sofern es überhaupt eine
gibt bevor er auf die menschliche zeit
zu sprechen kommt er verortet also die
zeitfrage in einem kosmologische
theologischen kontext schon mal sehr
interessanten
es gibt hier so 22 teile dieses zitat
eben erst mal die freiheit über die zeit
gottes und jetzt der begibt des seins
noch mal wichtig wie verstehen sie jetzt
hier das sein
hier im sein verfahren gemacht dass sein
es ist auch interessant verspricht dass
sein er substanziell wird das sein wird
es ist also fast schon wie so eine so
eine sphäre und nicht so eine art
prädikat jemand ist auch wenn sein kein
reales prädikat ist es kein richtiges
prädikat sei höchstens existieren aber
es ist ihm sein also dass seine art fair
oder so und die ist so hat eine art
homogenes fähre also art blog vielleicht
schon wirklich jetzt vorgestellt wo eben
nichts vergänglich ist und das ist ein
absolutes wehren und deswegen auch
verharren und eben diese ewigkeit
ok also also mit wenn wir von gott
sprechen können wir offensichtlich nicht
im normalen sinne von einer zeitlichen
existenz sprechen sondern wir müssen
zeit und gott dir im kausalen verhältnis
des ermöglichen schöpfen
das erschaffen es verstehen in diesem
sinne können wir vielleicht im sinne
dass das vorsprechen
ja
die erklärung dafür ausgesetzt ewigkeit
keiner zeit bedacht
das ist interessant genug maßeinheiten
gedanke auf dass bereichs unendliche
zeit wer die ewigkeit aber so wie sie
herr hinter im 16 doch schreibt ist vor
allem vergangene der ewigkeit daraus
muss es gar keine zeit unten hin fielen
genau erscheint jetzt hier ewigkeiten
mit sein mit diesem groß geschriebenen
zeilen verbindung das setzen also so
eine vorstellung von ewigkeit könnte man
sich auch so verstehen
man agiert einfach unendlich viel zeit
man summiert zeit unendlich auf
unendlich viele zeiteinheiten so denkt
er offensichtlich nicht die ewigkeiten
werden also ein guter punkt ewigkeit und
auch unendlichkeit sind deshalb die
ewigkeit unendlichkeit ist auch logisch
begrifflich sich recht schwer
vorzustellen
und es gibt eine tendenz unendlichkeit
zu veränderlichen oder ewigkeit zu
verdeutlichen
indem wir eben unendlichkeit oder
ewigkeit von endlichen beziehungsweise
vom zeitlichen her denken und glauben
bekämen durch addition wenn wir nur
genug zeitliche endlichen einheiten
addieren irgendwann mal zum endlichen
oder ewigen aber das unendlich ewig
erfolgt eine ganz anderen logik als es
das zeitlich unendliche tut und er sagte
zu die logik des ewigen ist die logik
des seins groß gesprochen und
offensichtlich so dass es eine vororten
bedeutet und diese verordnung könnte man
sagen ist die eine kausalität vielleicht
das sagte ziemlich direkt ich meine da
ist natürlich dieses geschaffen der die
zeit geschaffen hat ne hier
also verursachung natürlich grund
vielleicht könnte man auch sagen
fundierung die funktion ist das
fundament oder der grund grund ist
vielleicht auch nicht schlecht etwas hat
ist der grund einer anderen sache dann
ist der grund vor der anderen sache
jetzt nicht unbedingt zeitlich aber
logisch auf jeden fall und noch mehr
vielleicht auch noch genetisch oder
kausal oder ja also diese sind in dieser
causa schöpferischen sind und jetzt gibt
es diese zweite hälfte dieses
abgebildeten zitat ziehe und das ist
jetzt die überleitung zu dieser ganz
berühmten frage von augustinus was ist
aber zeit er sagt jetzt hier leben
zärtlich im alltag haben wir eigentlich
gar keine probleme über zahlen zu
sprechen es ist uns extrem vertraut und
gegenwärtig und auch in der lebens im
lebensweltlichen kontext der
kommunikation wir können darüber fast
schon reflexen oder darüber wirklich uns
rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen sprechen
und wir verstehen es auch im alltag wenn
jemand anderes von zeit spricht also wir
haben so ein alltags verständnis und das
unmittelbar das bewusstsein für eine
ungeschlagene vertrautheit mit zeit hat
mich ganz stark an martin heidegger
erinnert heiliger den wir am ende des
semesters lesen werden aus seinem werk
seinerzeit heiliger spricht so mit blick
auf das sein was ich damit auch die zeit
sagt das sein was ist in seinem seit
tiger im alltag ist das seil uns
vollständig vertraut aber überhaupt
keine probleme
wenn du jetzt aber darüber rechenschaft
ablegen sondern über das was das sein
ist dann bekommen wir riesige probleme
und genau das scheint auch in dem mit
dem thema zeit zu sein
gemeint nächste tat also dass gleich das
anschließende anschließend extra was
also ist die zeit wenn niemand mich
danach fragt weiß ich es also erstmal
geht es hier im vorherigen noch mal geht
es nicht muss fragen sind es geht ums
hören und uns aussprechen
insgesamt also das was nach außen hin
affirmativ behauptet und jetzt wird das
ganze plötzlich fraglich frage gestellt
was also ist die zeit wenn niemand mich
danach fragt weiß ich ist wenig es einen
fragenden kreieren will weiß ich es
nicht trotzdem behaupte ich fest zu
wissen dass es keine vergangene zeit
gebe wenn nichts vorübergehen keine
zukünftige zeit wenn nicht heran käme
und keine gegenwärtige zeit wenn es
nicht geben
das da ist wie kommt also jenen zwei
zeiten der vergangenen und der
zukünftigen seien zu da einerseits das
vergangene nicht mehr ist und
andererseits das zukünftige noch nicht
ist wenn das gegenwärtige aber immer
gegenwärtig werde und nicht ins
vergangen sein über ginge wäre es nicht
mehr zeit sondern ewigkeit frage ist
gottes zeit so eine permanente gegenwart
die gar nicht von der zukunft kommt und
in die vergangenheit über geht diese
sogenannten stars stripes mal hin alle
dieses setzt sich befindlichen dass der
stift leider ach das ist der hier
distanz also stehen jetzt stehen diese
dann verweilende zeit diese zeitlose
zeit könnte man auch sagen die zeit die
nicht ihrem fluss ist diese zeit in der
man vollständig aufgeben
das ist die substanz ich frage ob das
die göttliche zeit mein gott dann
überhaupt eine zeitliche dimension hat
angemessen erscheint augustinus wenn das
gegenwärtige aber immer gegenwärtig
währung nicht vergangen sein über ginge
wäre es nicht mehr zeit sondern ewigkeit
also wenn das gegenwärtige fixiert würde
in dem fluss der zeit fixiert und
isoliert würden
wenn also das gegenwärtige um zeit zu
sein deshalb im sein kommt weil es in
das vergangen sein übergeht wie können
wir auch im insein zu sprechen wo der
grund seines seins doch gut darin
besteht dass es sogleich nicht mehr da
sein wird können wir wirklich nur
deshalb behaupten dass die zeit ist bei
sitzungen nicht sein strebt
ich schaue jetzt haben wir also wirklich
sehr sehr viele fragen also ich hatte in
der letzten sitzung zur eröffnung dieses
seminars diesen ersten teil dieses
zitats im präsentiert wo augustinus sagt
wenn mich dann jemand danach fragt wenn
mich jemand fragt und ich rechenschaft
ablegen sondern dies begründen soll was
es denn ist wenn ich doch behauptet ist
wisse es dann bekomme ich große probleme
das zu erklären
also wenn ich aus dieser intuitiven
unmittelbaren vertrautheit mit dem mit
dem thema zeit wenn ich das wenn ich die
zeit sozusagen auf den begriff bringen
bestellen wenn ich sie reflektieren
möchte dann bekomme ich probleme
und jetzt beginnt der hier diese analyse
der zeit könnte man sagen
mit dem 3 momenten oder drei dimensionen
der zeit des zukünftigen gegenwärtigen
und vergangenen und jetzt wollen wir uns
mal hier bisschen grafisch überlegen wie
man sich das vorstellen kann also es
scheint so zu sein dass zeit wir ganz am
ende sagt dass die zeit zum nichts zum
nicht sein hin strebt vom noch nicht der
zukunft zum jetzt zum existierenden aber
der unmittelbar dann zum nicht sein aber
jetzt überlegen uns heute sagen wie man
das jetzt also mal grafisch hier sich
genauer vorstellen könnte
haben sie ideen ich zeichne jetzt mal
hier ich schreibe zwar in zukunft
gegenwart und vergangenheit schon damit
hängt jetzt an wie sollen wir sie
überhaupt anordnen
sollen wir jetzt die zukunft sozusagen
rechts an der tafel die gegenwart und
die mitte und die vergangenheit links
auf so einer horizontalen gerade
anordnen oder soll man es nicht lieber
vertikal angeordnet
das sei also zu weit oben die gegenwart
ist so in der mitte und die
vergangenheit ist unten reagiert die
zeit hat einrichtung und in der
mathematik oder in der physik genauer
über die zeit immer so ein bisschen als
als x-achse also angelegt auf die
x-achse projiziert und machen wir jetzt
auch einfach mal als x-achse
o
wie könnte ich jetzt diese drei
dimensionen derzeit eine verbindung
setzen haben sie eine idee wie soll ich
jetzt den zeit teil hier ansetzen
von rechts nach links also praktisch die
zukunft heißt deswegen zukunft weil sie
auf uns zukommt also so und hier na ja
eigentlich ist das überflüssig ja aber
die vergangenheit
wenn man das jetzt also mal würde dem
die zukunft nur dann wäre es so wir
wären natürlich hier und zwar immer und
so oder so eine these von mir wir können
darüber diskutiert ich habe nicht
vergessen
dann wäre es so wir sind fix irgendwie
wir sind fixiert wir sind in der
gegenwart fixiert und die zeit läuft
sagen auf und zu die zukunft kommt auf
uns zu und läuft durch uns hindurch
sowie passiert uns gewissermaßen also
könnte man sich das vorstellen
das hatten sie sich gemeinde
ich glaube nicht dass meine ich bin also
ich glaube augustin hat zeigt
wahrscheinlich schon sowas wie ne
[Musik]
sie alle haben guten punkt gebracht man
könnte jetzt ein alternatives modell auf
machen und sagen müssen muss mir den
feierlichen der andere richtung drehen
also sollten wir den zeit dass man sieht
auch so ein bisschen von der gegenwart
zu tun also die alternative wäre die den
zeitfahr jetzt mal andersrum hin zu
zeichnen
okay sie würden also sagen so als auch
nicht von rechts nach links sind von
links nach rechts
sie haben sich mehr das war die die
these des kommilitonen genau das war die
vorherige wenn du mal zukunft sagt ja
auch schon das die zukunft ist das zu
kommende das was auf uns zukommt also
von uns an der gegenwart aus gesehen
müsste das dann auf uns hin zu laufen
auf und durch und sind durchgehend das
war so die die these des komitee und das
hat man hier eine gegenmeinung mit gegen
auffassung dass man sagt er gut in der
in der physik da ist derzeit zahlt immer
sohn von links nach rechts hin zur
zukunft gerichtet sollten wir nicht
vielleicht zu anzeichnen bitte
nein stimmen
so gemeint dass mit vergangenheit und
zukunft sich praktisch an ihren wir in
der gegenwart praktisch unendlich
gleichen tun
gewisse weise spricht eine subjektivität
der zeit und das vergangene ist es
sowohl vergangenheit weil ich eine art
erinnerung ist also das was wir
unterhalten sich und er in zukunft ihre
hypothek stören es aber beim schlafen im
unendlich klein pumpen
dann würde ihre vergangenheit und
zukunft vielleicht gleichzeitig auf mich
zukommen wenn es uns unendlich klein
kommen ja also es wäre eine möglichkeit
also ich verstehe jetzt nur noch nicht
wie die vergangenheit auf uns zukommen
könnte
aber sie meine es wahrscheinlich so dass
eben im gegenwärtigen eigentlich schon
die zukünftige moment das vergangene
immer schon so anwesen ist oder anklickt
kann sie verstehen weiß dass nach
unendlich klein genau da kommen wir auch
noch drauf also wir wir kommen noch auf
diese ganzen anderen passagen wir wollen
jetzt einfach nur mal also logisch von
anfang an nach hinten schreiben jetzt
hatten sie noch verschiedene anbringen
meldete
sehr gut über wir noch auf die
vergangenheit bestimmt
würden wir die ganzen
gutes argument genau sie würden sagen
also die vergangenheit kann deswegen
nicht nichts sein weil sie eine
bedeutung für uns hat und wir auch aus
der vergangenheit uns wie jetzt zum
beispiel haltiger sagen wird in die
zukunft zu entwerfen
also heiliger sieht das dann ganz anders
ich mach mal kurz die tür zu
sonst so eine meldung hatte sich sonst
noch jemand gemeldet also wir wollen
jetzt auch noch mal die ganzen optionen
her auf den tisch legen also wir wollen
auch gar nicht jetzt uns entscheidend
sind und was gibt's denn hierfür
optionen bitte
ist ok genau das ist ein guter punkt
also das ist es gibt diese zwei
möglichkeiten wie verstehen wir uns als
objekt sind wir ihnen sagen sind wir im
zeitlichen kontinuum fixiert und läuft
die zeit durch uns hindurch von der
zukunft kommend auf uns hin zu stellen
wir uns als erleben das objekt als da
wäre immer gegenwärtig sind als fixiert
vor oder ist es nicht vielmehr so dass
wir auf derzeit reiten so zu sagen wir
wir bewegen uns nach vorne sagen also
ist es ist selber relativ also es kann
sein etwas kommt auf uns zu läuft durch
uns endlich im oder wir bewegen uns in
der zeit nach vorne diese zwei
möglichkeiten gibt es das ist das jetzt
ein bisschen diese dieses dieser punkt
wo wir jetzt bei augustinus geraten sind
möglichkeit dass wir das
heute ist und
in richtung genau also man könnte noch
mal eine andere ebene einführen
die vielleicht dann nicht so sehr jetzt
die bewegung wie veranschaulicht sondern
ihr so eine tendenz eine
erwartungshaltung bewusst sein als sie
sehen es gibt große probleme wie wir uns
jetzt die richtung derzeit überhaupt
vorstellen sollen das hängt davon ab wie
wir uns als erleben dass objekte denken
sind wir fix oder reiten wir auch
derzeit also läuft die zeit durch und
sie durch sieht wie das medium auf dass
die zeit so kommt und das alles erleidet
ist auch eine frage ob wir uns das
subjekt derzeit als etwas aktives oder
passives vorstellen wenn wir sonst etwas
passives vorstellen dann sind wir das
medium durch das die zukunft hindurch
läuft und sich daneben durchlaufen in
die vergangenheit transformiert werden
und passives verständnis da die zukunft
ist das was auf uns zukommt oder
verstehen wir das objekt derzeit eher
als etwas aktives dass sich ihnen
derzeit bewegt man sich nach vorne
bewegt dieser zeit
genau
also sie sehen hier gibt es ganz
verschiedene möglichkeiten die man sieht
sie das subjekt vorstellen kann also
heiliger wird dann vom dasein sprechen
heiliger spricht nicht vom subjekt und
da sind der sagt wir entwerfen uns aus
der vergangenheit in die zukunft und von
dort wieder wenn ich zurück er spricht
einiger schon mal vorweg zugreifen
spricht auch nicht so sehr von der
zukunft von der gegenwart von der
vergangenheit sondern er hat andere
begriffe in seiner technologie aber ich
wollte damit nur sagen wir haben jetzt
hier verschiedene mögliche konstellation
denkmodell wie man sich jetzt das
subjekt derzeit vorstellen kann und wir
wollen das jetzt erstmal auch mal offen
lassen sie wurde jetzt nämlich
entscheiden also wichtig ist dass wir
sind herausgearbeitet haben wir können
uns als etwas passives vorstellen
durch das die zeit in durchläuft dann
kommt die zeit auf 16 uhr wurde wir
können uns als welt er das aktiveres
vorstellen was in der zeit die jetzt
fixiert gedacht wird nach vorne bewegt
auf derzeit reitet und das ist natürlich
auch ein riesenthema dann dass der frage
nach der veränderung die bewegung wie
muss man sich überhaupt bewegung denken
in der nächsten sitzung bei aristoteles
gibt es noch eine weitere meldung zu
diesen diesen ganz rudimentären ganz
generieren konstellationen der zeit
wir lesen sind einfach mal weiter
also jetzt es geht es um diesen prekären
und logischen status derzeit prima
fahrschein von diesen traditionen sie
überhaupt wird die frage wie wir von
gegenwart vergangenheit zukunft den
blick auf die zeit reden soll sind es
dimensionen dimensionen würde so ein
bisschen nahelegen sind sogleich
gleichwertig es gibt ja da schon
unterschied die also die gegenwart die
hebt sich auf bestimmte weise von der
vergangenheit oder zukunft ab muss
irgend ausgezeichnet wie sollen wir
davon sprechen sind das momente
derzeit sind es ekstasen derzeit sind es
phänomene der zeit also da müssen wir
uns auch noch gedanken dazu machen wie
wir vergangen bad vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft begrifflich
klassifizieren soll
vielleicht haben sie auch noch ideen
also was ist eigenschaften der zeit sind
sind es formen der zeit da müssen wir
noch mal genau ins gedanken dazu machen
also es strebt offensichtlich zeigt
jetzt augustinus ins nichts
sobald die zeit nach diesem verständnis
des passiven subjekts durch uns hindurch
gelaufen ist wird sie zum nichts wird
sie zur vergangenheit
jetzt geht es weiter sagt und doch reden
wir fangen langer zeit und kurzer zeit
auch wenn wir das nur blick auf
vergangene oder zukünftiges tun sprechen
wir zb von 100 jahren die vorbei sind
zum einen wir eine lange zeit vergangen
ist ebenso meinen wir mit 100 jahren die
bevorstehen eine lange zeit die
zukünftig ist als kurze zeit der
vergangenheit bezeichnen wir aber zum
beispiel zehn tage die vorbei sind
als kurze zeit der zukunft zehn tage die
bevorstehen wie ich übereinkunft erlaubt
uns aber etwas lange oder kurze nennt
das nicht ist der vergangenheit dass
dies nicht mehr zukünftiges ist noch
nicht deshalb sollten wir von
vergangenen nicht sagen es ist lang
sondern es war lang und vom zukünftigen
es wird lang sein
was ist das denn jetzt hier für eine
strategie um dieses problem zu lösen
dass wir eigentlich nur von etwas im
sinne von langen kurz sprechen können
was existieren was ist die strategie
ja also gut also gute frage als in der
in der physik ist es ja auch so dass man
den zeitpunkt t von delta t unter
scheint als ob meine zeitdifferenz nimmt
oder als einfach als fünf sekunden her
ist es was ist das ist das ein wert den
man einsetzt eine formel fünf sekunden
oder betrag wenn man die fünf sekunden
unter dem aspekt der zeitdauer
es ist ein wunder punkt ist eine gute
frage haben sie eine idee wie könnte man
darauf antworten
die anderen teilnehmer
haben sie selbst nehmen die genauso man
könnte jetzt zum beispiel sagen zeit ist
einfach die tatsache dass sich etwas
verändert die tatsache dass etwas von
der zukunft in die gegenwart und von
dort in die vergangenheit übergeht das
ist das zeitlichkeit kann man auch ein
zeitlichkeit die tatsache dass etwas im
verlauf begriffen ist im team sind
dieses ablaufen dieser stadien könnte
sagen also man kann sich zum beispiel
fragen sind vergangenheit gegenwart
zukunft stadien der zeitlichkeit es in
einem stadium
wenn die jetzt einen guten guten begriff
dafür ein stadium könnte ja vielleicht
auch sagen es sind potenzen oder sowas
sind aber statisch stadien finde ich
jetzt noch nicht schlecht und davon
müssen wir von diesen generellen
phänomen der zeitlichkeit dass sich
etwas diesem sinne verändert auf und zu
kommt oder wie auch in diesem medium
vorangehen dafür müssen wir dann
sicherlich die konkrete zeitdauer
unterscheiden und das könnte man dann im
sinne eines recht objektiven begriffs
des betrags zum beispiel machen also
mathematisch der betrag der betrag von
55 tagen und bleibt erster unberührt ob
das jetzt fünf tage der vergangenheit
sind oder fünf tage der zukunft wenn man
es nur ganz allgemein abstrakt wir
nehmen diesen betrag fünf tage diese
zeitdauer
das wäre dann erst sei unabhängig von
der konkreten verortung innerhalb dieser
staaten oder dimensionen objektiver
begrifflichkeit der betrag fünf tage
oder interessiert uns die zeit darauf in
fünf tagen das sieht uns jetzt nicht
waren die jetzt oder sind sie noch nicht
werden sie sein werden
und das führt dann auch zu diesen wäre
ein bei mctaggart also der unterscheidet
gerade zwischen diesen verschiedenen
dimensionen von zeit dass wir sollen wir
haben sie zeit beträge oder absolute
konstellationen und wir haben auf der
anderen seite diese subjektive
zeitempfinden wird aber noch genügend
der betrag sei die sprache dessen also
dass man eine vergangene zeit nicht als
land bezeichnen kann ich sagen das ist
genau genau also die frage ist wie
können wir sehr gut also wie können wir
über vergangen ist wir sind der dauer
es war fünf tage wo doch die rede der
dauer ist so gewählt dass es gegenwärtig
während man es meinen sie oder wenn ich
sage es dauert fünf tage
in der vergangenheit dann tue ich so als
ob es gegenwärtig wäre wohl es jetzt zur
vergangenheit gehören
genau also offensichtlich ist hier die
lösung er unternimmt die sonne modelle
oder sollen ja eine moderne rede von von
zeitdauer als er muss sagen oder
versieht sie mit einem index also fünf
tage vergangen mit einem index oder ein
modus fünf tage im modus des vergangenen
fünf tage im modus des zukünftigen also
muss es noch mal zusätzlich bezeichnen
ok also eine moderne sicht der dauer
das wäre dann nicht dass wir dann
unterschiedliche modelle sich diese mit
index versehene form der zeit wäre zu
unterscheiden von dieser von diesem
betrag von diesen von diesen absoluten
begriff
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten wir können
von dauer sprechen überblick wann war
das
die verortung innerhalb dieses dieser
stadien von uns aus gesehen also diese
dieser subjektive bindung das wäre die
subjektive bindung an uns wäre diese
modelle rede war ist von dieser zeit
dauern
wir können aber auch eine sehr abstrakte
von uns als zugeht derzeit erfahrung
losgelöste auffassung von dauer
vertreten
und dann wäre das einfach das pure
faktum fünf tage und da ist dann
uninteressant ob es tage war fünf tage
sein wird das werde ich jetzt einfach
mal der betrag fünf abstrahiert von
allen zeitlichen subjektiven an das
subjekt des verfahrens gebundenen ja
umständen sage jetzt mal
genauso so eine moderne wird und ich
greife immer schon ein bisschen vorweg
vielleicht sollten auch diesen text von
magath ein bisschen vorziehen müssen wir
nochmal überlegen weil hier wird sehr
deutlich dass man von zeit und zwei
hinsichten sprechen kann zeitlichkeit im
sinne das modell sein muss dass es
bezogen sein muss auf uns als subjekt
derzeit erfahrung die wir eine zukunft
vor uns haben eine vergangenheit hinter
uns haben und einer dauer die einfach
unabhängig von unserer subjektiven
stellung zur gegenwart zur vergangenheit
und zukunft versuchen zukunft ist dass
ich den betrag der zeit nehmen jetzt
habe ich aber noch landen punkt der mir
jetzt gerade eingefallen ist wenn ich
jetzt sage die zeit ist vor uns die zeit
ist hinter uns
was mache ich denn dann mit der zeit das
ist ein punkt den heiliger sehr häufig
kritisieren wird ja genau damals ich
kann nämlich im sinne von vor
also diese präposition vorhat einmal
zeitlichen aspekt dann hat sie ihren
logischen aspektes haben wir schon
gesehen irakischen aspekt vielleicht
auch ne also was ist wer ist denn die
vorgeordnet die vorgesetzte personen das
ist die vorgesetzte und jetzt hat aber
auch ein räumliches vor dem haus vor der
türe vor mir oder hinter mir person also
das ist die das ist eine problematik
dass wir immer schon dazu tendieren
zeitlichkeit uns sofort zu stelle sei es
etwas räumliches indem ich sie jetzt
hier an die tafel gemalt habe die zeit
skizziert habe habe ich sie schon wieder
verheimlicht ich bin nach rechts und
nach links rechts und links ja kommt sie
jetzt auf uns zu von rechts nach links
von links nach rechts
das sind alles räumliche
veranschaulichung derzeit das müssen wir
uns immer bewusst sein dass die große
probleme haben von zeit so zu sprechen
ohne es räumlich kategorien auf sie
anzuwenden
das problem der verheimlichung derzeit
das hat verteidiger ein wichtiger punkt
wert also wir können jetzt hier
festhalten aus diesem zitat wir können
und zwei hinsichten von sei dauer
sprechen von diesem absoluten begriff
den betrag fünf jahre oder von diesem
relativen auf das subjekt der zeit
erfahren kunden sinne dass wir sagen
fünf jahre unter dem gesichtspunkt der
vergangenheit fünf jahre unter dem
gesichtspunkt der zukunft wenn wir es
auf uns beziehen als subjekt
müssen wir nicht machen wir können auch
einfach nur mathematisch oder
physikalisch von den betrag sprechen
ein physiker interessiert in der regel
auch nicht ob es jetzt fünf zukünftig
jahre sind aber fünf vergangenen jahr
und den physiker interessiert einfach
nur die zeitdauer im betrag
und das ist so ein wichtiger punkt weil
die philosophie interessiert eben gerade
die subjektive bindung also ob es jetzt
in der zukunft sein wird oder der
vergangenheit wenn ich eine formel habe
und was ausrechnen will dann gebe ich
den betrag ein
die zeitdauer beachtet der
gegenwärtigkeit oder der vergangenheit
und der zukunft also die physik könnte
man sagen die abstrahiert von dieser
modalen bindung an der subjekt referenz
von der referenz ali t
der dimensional i tät derzeit davon
abstrahiert die physik und das ist einer
dieser gründe weshalb eben doch der
philosophische zeitbegriff doch ein
bisschen fundamentaler ist als der
physikalische zeitbegriff an da die
subjektivität eigentlich keine rolle
gespielt und das ist eine voraussetzung
die man zumindest hinterfragen muss ob
wir wirklich so von derzeit abstrahiert
reden können angemessen oder ob da nicht
einiges verloren gehen ok also wir haben
jetzt schon ziemlich viel rausziehen
können aus diesem zitat diesmal einfach
mal weiter wie war die vergangene zeit
die lang gewesen ist entlang als sie
bereits vergangen war oder als sie noch
gegenwärtig war
sie konnte dort nur langsam als etwas
gar das lang sein konnte weil das
vergangene damals aber nicht mehr war
konnte die zeit nicht lang sein weil sie
überhaupt nicht wahr
es sollten also es nicht sagen dass eine
vergangene zeit lang war denn wir werden
ja nichts finden was lang wäre weil sie
ja seit sie vergangen ist richtig ist
vielmehr sollten wir sagen lang war jene
gegenwärtige zeit weil sie lang war als
sie gegenwärtig war denn da war sie noch
nicht zum nicht sein übergegangen und
war insofern etwas
dass die möglichkeit hätte lang zu sein
nachher aber als vergangen war hörte sie
zugleich auf lang zu sein weil sie zu
sein aufgehört hat also um eine
zeitliche dauer zu haben muss etwas in
der gegenwart abspielen und wir können
sagt jetzt augustinus eigentlich nicht
angemessen von einer vergangenen dauer
sprechen weil dauer ja den modus der
gegenwärtigkeit gegeben etwas muss
andauern das muss ich andauernd zur
gegenwart gehören ja was kann man jetzt
das sagen
eigentlich hatte er schon die antwort
auf diese frage im vorherigen zitat
gegeben wir müssen eben immer relativ
davon sprechen also fünf jahre eben
vergangenheit fünf jahre der das ehemals
präsent gewesen als jetzt eben zur
vergangenheit zählt ja
ja also das ist doch mal eine
zusätzliche dimension
das wäre jetzt eine andere form von
subjektivität der zeit als ich denke wir
müssen zwei formen der subjektivität
derzeit unterscheiden
wir haben bis jetzt so von subjektivität
zählt derzeit gesprochen als
zeitlichkeit immer gegenwärtigkeit
vergangenheit und zukunft
berücksichtigen muss dass das
irgendeinen unterschied macht ob ich
jetzt fünf jahre in der zukunft habe die
fünf jahren der vergangenheit das ist
die subjektive bindung derzeit in dem
sinne als sie bezogen wird auf ein
subjekt als orientierungspunkt jetzt
geht es natürlich noch einen anderen
begriff der subjektivität derzeit den
aber augustinus so nicht behandelt das
ist einfach wie schnell die zeit vergeht
die zeit verging jetzt aber schneller
genau
[Musik]
oder ich bin das modell was jetzt
bringen ist tatsächlich er sein ein
vertikales modell das dann ebenso ein
schiffsmodell wissen also die ich kann
es mal hin malen
also wäre unten die vergangenheit
sie merken ich freue mich schon wieder
ich sage jetzt unten ich sage jetzt
nicht mehr links und rechts ich sage
jetzt unten oben wäre die zukunft oben
und die gegenwart wäre irgendwie hier
vielleicht wenn wir wird sagen beide
spielen somit rein so vielleicht ja und
hier sind wir so eingespannt in diese
dimension war auch eine möglichkeit
also so wir sind irgendwie sowie in ein
sandwich sind wir einfach so zwischen
zwei hälften der switches sind wir
eingezwängt muss jetzt auch nicht als
zwang gedeutet werden wir sind einfach
verortet in der mitte und zwar so dass
die immer beide präsenz die werden also
gegenwart und zu werden vergangenheit
und zukünftig kite als präsent gedacht
in jedem zeitpunkt also sie haben eine
bedeutung für uns ja dass das gegen das
vergangene das trägt uns auch in einer
gewissen weise also ist unser fundament
könnte mir absagte
und das ist unser unser ausblick oder
unser dach oder so was also der horizont
die zukunft
dann könnte sich das auch vorstellen
jetzt hat sich ganz hinten jemand
gemeldet
aber irgendwo ist
in der sport- und zwar nicht komplett
frei vor bestimmen
addiere ich das ist noch ein weiteres
interessantes thema also wie freiheit
und zeigen nach zusammenhängen
augustinus sagt geht es da nicht soviel
dazu diesen text jedenfalls nicht aber
bei haltiger werden wir darauf dann noch
mehr zu sprechen kommt das eben die
vergangenheit
wichtig ist aber ich würde es dann auch
bei heiligen und auch bei augustinus
nicht als zwang sehen sind wirklich als
fundament also eher positiv gedeutet die
vergangenheit denkt sie auch zurück an
die damalige zeit da war die tradition
noch viel wichtiger als wir uns
heutzutage das bewahren das
dokumentieren die die sitten und so was
in dieser zeit denke ich hat die
vergangenheit eine sehr positive
bedeutung während tendenziell heutzutage
vielleicht könnte man sagen der
vergangenheit eher zum ballast gesehen
wird von dem man sich befreien möchte
bei der unseren unsere zukünftig kite
behindern
also wir sind so sehr gebunden und
können nicht so sehr in die zukunft
streben es hält uns fest in der
vergangenheit wir sind nicht so flexibel
also ich glaube dass an die
vergangenheit ja in der geschichte dafür
dass so viele recht positive bedeutung
hat und dass ihr das gegenwärtige form
der das zeitlichkeit denkens ist dass
man die zukunft stärker macht aber das
war eine riesen debatte für sich wie man
wie sich diese einschätzung und die
philosophische bewertung der dimensionen
der zeit geändert hat und mit welchen
gründen man verhalte jetzt auch die
vergangenheit sehr wichtig weil wir uns
von der vergangenheit in die zukunft
entwerfen und erst im entwurf auf die
zukunft gegenwärtig existenz haben als
er versucht diese drei dimensionen auf
eine ganz interessante weise miteinander
zu verbinden
die beiden trainer
hier haben
genau also es gibt da im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert vor allem eine ganz neue
form des zeit denkens
[Musik]
das
zweite wurden zeitreihe vielleicht
möglich
ja es muss auch nicht eingeklemmt also
muss nicht jetzt ich habe bezahlt mal
gesagt kein gegeben das kann auch
einfach sein
vor ort situiert man hat einen platz
zugewiesen mann ruht oder man hat dieses
fundament der vergangenheit das muss
audi als und zwangs immer gedacht es
[Musik]
gibt dann immer diese versuche diese
gegenwart zu verstetigen das ist immer
schon so eine tendenz auch in der
philosophie das ist dieses monster hans
dieses jetzt stehen diese ewigkeit der
gegenwart also dieses verhindern dass
die gegenwart in die vergangenheit über
gegner dieses sich dagegen stemmen gegen
dieses nichtigkeit
auf einem ist aber auch im kommentar
genau da gibt es die zukunft also die
zukunft haben wir natürlich auch nur
begrenzt in der hand na also wenn jetzt
die frage nach der freiheit wieder
stellen die vergangenheit können wir
nicht mehr ändern wenn wir die freiheit
irgendwie verordnen wollen dann ist sie
traditionell natürlich in der gegenwart
wir können versuchen planungen
anzustellen bezüglich der zukunft aber
wie die zukunft kommen wird das wissen
wir eben im zeigt wenn ich da kommt
jemand bestimmtes moment des risikos mit
dem spiel aber natürlich auch eine
gewisse offenheit die uns alternative
möglichkeiten anbietet es ist vielleicht
noch nicht ganz determiniert was eine
kurz zukunft sein wird riesen frage
wieder steht die zukunft schon fest oder
nicht dastehen können wir ganz viele
andere interessante frage anschließen
als sie haben sehr zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eben uns diese drei
staaten derzeit auf ganz verschiedene
weise vorstellen können wie können sie
uns auf eine horizontale achse
projiziert denken wie wir es zuerst
gemacht haben wir können sogar umkehren
vertikal sehen und dann stellt sich
immer die frage wie verhalten sich
bitteschön dann vergangenheit und
zukunft zum gegenwärtigen und augustinus
hat eine sehr klare sicht der dinge
er hat er sieht es offensichtlich so das
wetter geht stark vom seien aus
augustinus hat einen starken
theologischen zucker er spricht vom sein
und wenn etwas eigentlich ist und kann
es nur gegenwärtig sein weil die
vergangenheit ist ja nicht mehr da ist
das ja nicht mehr als wir sprechen
eigentlich im falschen sinne von sein
der vergangenheit weil was gewesen ist
ist ja nicht mehr und die zukunft ist
auch nicht eigentlich weil es ist ja
noch nicht gewesen
also eigentlich ist nur die gegenwart
und theologisch relevant wir können
nicht nur vom jetzt im sinne des sein
sprechen und wenn wir uns das jetzt aber
genauer anschauen werden wir feststellen
dass wir es auch nicht richtig dingfest
machen können weil dieses jetzt alle
wollen jetzt den blick bisschen auf
dieses zentrum legen dieser gegenwart
dieses jetzt höchst prekär ist ständig
im wandel begriffen wie können wir es
dann ontologisch bestimmen überhaupt hat
es überhaupt hat überhaupt die gegenwart
einen seien wenn sie doch permanent im
übergang begriffen ist und der in
zukunft zur vergangenheit
dies ist eigentlich nur so medium durch
das die zeit hindurch strömen
aber jetzt noch einmal das nächste lesen
sie hatten eine meldung
exakt formulieren ist doch so 1 assist
zu brechen könnte man vielleicht zwei
drei zeiten von vergangenen gegen mann
von gmbh für zukünftige wissen genau da
kommen noch drauf ist ein guter punkt
entscheidend ist bei der aris augustin
mischen sich dass es auf die vermögen
des objektes bezogen wird also
augustinus ritt die gegenwart und
wirklich vergangenheit und die zukunft
als die des subjekts deuten also wird
deren realität nicht ontologisch
objektiv besuchen zu begründen und da
ist augustinus jetzt gerade noch in den
passagen und sind sind wird ihnen ihre
eigenständigkeit ihrer realität nur
durch bezug auf das objekt was ich zu
ihnen verhält suchen zu erkunden ja also
die zukunft ist eben modus vielleicht
der hoffnung ein bestimmter modus des
der aktivität des subjekts oder an
aktivität der seele also die die
zeitlichkeit wird über die aktivität der
seele bestellen und nicht unlogisch
absolut nicht wir es jetzt hier gemacht
hatten hier haben wir auch kein bezug
auf die aktivitäten und die
vergangenheit wird über einen sehen
vermögen der erinnerung memory dann
erklären da kommen wir noch darauf aber
wichtig ist ebenfalls das nicht und
theologisch unabhängig vom subjekt ist
kann die realität derzeit in ihrem drei
dimensionen nur durch bezug auf das
subjekt und seine seele vermögen
erklären aber es ist ein richtiger
hinweis also der schlüssel ist das zitat
weise gebracht hat diesen problemen
ok und jetzt kennen sie jetzt geht das
spiel also weiter jetzt sagte okay wenn
jetzt hier also nur die gegenwart
wirklich zeit ist dann müssen wir jetzt
bestimmen was eigentlich gegenwärtig ist
und jetzt sagte lass uns um menschen zu
sehen ob eine gegenwärtige zeit lang
sein kann den die es gegeben der
menschenseele zeit spannend wahrzunehmen
und zu messen was wirst du mir antworten
sind 100 gegenwärtig jahre eine lange
zeit dass sie zunächst ob 100 jahre
wirklich gegenwärtig sein können wenn
von diesen jahren nämlich das erste
abläuft ist eben dieses jahr gegenwärtig
und 99 aber stehen noch bevor sie sind
also noch nicht wenn aber das zweite
jahr läuft ist eines schon vergangenheit
ein anderes gegenwärtige übrigen aber
stehen noch aus 8 19
so können wir jedes beliebige zwischen
anfang und ende dieser 100 zahl als
gegenwärtig setzen von ihm werden
jeweils vergangene jahr seien vor ihm
nach ihm
zukünftige demzufolge können 100 jahren
nicht gegenwärtig seien
und jetzt kann man das spiel weiter
treiben jetzt gehen wir halt von 100
jahren auf ein jahr
sie weiter wenigstens das eine jahr das
gerade läuft gegenwärtig ist denn auch
da gilt wenn sein erster monat läuft
sind die übrigen zukünftig auf den
zweiten monat februar ist der erste
januar schon vergangen gegen übrigen
aber sind noch nicht da
also ist auch das gerade laufende jahr
nicht als ganzes gegen relativ und wenn
es nicht als ganz gegenwärtig ist ist
nicht das jahr gemeldet in einem jahr
besteht aus zwölf monaten von dem der
jeweilige einzelnen monat der gerade
läuft für sich gegenwärtig ist die
übrigen aber sind wieder vergangen oder
zukünftig dennoch ist auch ein gerade
laufenden monat nicht gegenwärtig sind
ihr ein tag läuft der erste tag sind die
übrigen tage zu künftig läuft der letzte
tag sind die übrigen vergangen läuft ein
beliebiger mittlerer tag steht er
zwischen den vergangen und den zukunft
gegen tagen und jetzt können wir
natürlich dass mit dem tag auch genauso
machen mit einer stunde sagte jetzt hier
so hat sich die gegenwärtige zeit von
der anleihen gewannen das seal
anzunehmen sei auf die dauer kaum eines
tages verkürzt aber zu spalten wir auch
diese zeitspanne dann nicht einmal ein
tag als ganzer gegenwärtig ist
denn mit der dauer der nacht und des
tages füllt sie zusammen 24 stunden aus
die zeitspanne des tages während der
ersten stunde sind die übrigen zukünftig
in der letzten sind sie vergangen für
eine dazwischen liegende aber sind die
vergangenen für beide zukünftigen stimme
aus und selbst eine stunde wird in
flüchtigen teilchen durchlebt da hätte
ich jetzt gerne die lateinische stelle
vielleicht können sie mal nachschauen
was er da sagt diese flüchtigen teilchen
das können sie mal gerne nachschauen
flüchtig vgt war wahrscheinlich half
aktiver also sie kennen vielleicht auch
den spruch tempus fugit schon mal gehört
also es gibt diesen spruch häufig auf
uhren auf älteren schönen uhren aus
schönem holz und mit schönen messingen
messing gearbeiteten zeigern und uhr
pendeln oder schön gewichten die da
dranhängen
haben sie mal nachgeschaut was diese
flüchtigen teilchen sind können sie mal
nachschauen ob sie den 29 ich lief es
danach ja genau
ja und da vorgeht evo ist genau also
fugitive altevogt aldi die fuga also die
flucht auch eine interessante metapher
wie so flieht denn die zeit also gar
nichts kurs wie fleet denn die zeit
fliegt sie für uns wie muss man sich das
so vorstellen wenn die zeit fliegt wenn
man das sagt wir stellen sich das vor
die zeit rennt weg die zeit verrinnt die
zeit für uns oder favorit sind
die zeit ist ein idol
interessant ist die zeit als subjekt
gefasst dass auch interessante phänomene
nicht wir sind das objekt das die zeit
empfindet sind wir projizieren
vielleicht sogar uns in die zeit hinein
die zeit als objekt ist die zahl
überhaupt das objekt auch das höchst
problematisch die beiden sind schon
problematische zeit als ein objekt sich
zu denken wir sprechen immer von der
zeit als einen gegenstand wir
verheimlichen die zeit hierfür zeitlich
nicht zeit aber immer als ein gegenstand
ist die zeit überhaupt ein gegenstand
der uns als etwas von dem wir
unterschieden sind entgegensteht ich
glaube nicht warum nicht warum kann die
zeit kein gegenstand sein oder was das
problem jedenfalls dass wir die zeit als
ein gegenstand denkt der vor uns steht
wie jetzt zum beispiel hier
dieser computer und dieses mikrofone
genau da müssen wir uns selbst als und
zeitlich denken aber wir sind ja immer
in der zeit wir können aus der zeit gar
nicht raus also die zeit kann für uns
kein gegenstand sein
das ist schon eine interessante
beobachtung die zahl der rahmen
innerhalb dessen überhaupt auch das
denken über die zeit stattfinden kann
und sie sind es auch die nach der farbe
hier können
erfahrungen
der grund ist die zeit verrinnt einfach
sehr schnell die zeit läuft sehr schnell
ab die zeit kommt auf uns zu aber rennt
uns dann vorne also ich würde sagen in
diesem diagramm die flucht
die fluchtbewegung wäre jetzt in meinen
augen mal das ja vielleicht auch wieder
von der zukunft kommt aber das
entscheidende ist hier dass sie uns
entrinnt zu durch die hände rind aber
von uns weg rennt in die vergangenheit
rind oder wo würden sie sagen wo sie hin
rennt ja
ja die ergebnisse werden zur
vergangenheit richtig genau ist zwar
ganz hinten eine ja genau die zeit
verrinnt die wir können sie nicht packen
weil wenn wir sie packen wollen wollen
wir sie fixieren und wir wollen sie aus
diesem lauf der zeit heraus nehmen aber
sobald wir sie fassen sie schon wieder
weg genau also ist auch so dieses
problem so könnte man auch sagen die
zeit entwischt uns immer wir können sie
nicht greifen was natürlich auch ein
grund dafür ist dass sie kein objekt ist
wenn wir sie nicht fixieren können ich
bewahre jetzt mal diese zeit auf ich
stelle jetzt diese zeit diese zeit
diesem zeitpunkt in den same ein
panzerschrank es war so ein schöner
zeitpunkt den behäbig jetzt aufgekommen
zu einem panzerschrank rein damit er
nicht geklaut wird
oder ist er ihnen ein museum stellen
außen ein schaukasten dieser zeitpunkt
ist ein problem
ganz in frage
wenn
und
dann hören wir auf dieser ebene der
ebene übergeben
diese schritte aus und um
denken und da war sie überglücklich über
zeigen
ein guter punkt genau wir können
jedenfalls versuchen die zeit zum
begriff zu machen ein begriff von zeit
zu gewinnen und es macht ja auch
augustinus gerade aber wir lesen jetzt
mal weiter wir werden sehen dass er
große probleme damit hat und zwar
deswegen weil eben das bedeuten würde
dass uns zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
oder zu sagen moment einfach mal
begrifflich uns auch da bietet das sie
mal sie zu uns präsentiert dass wir sie
objektiv beschreiben können wenn wir
könnten ja sagen objektiv das objektive
an der zeit ist dass sie subjektiv ist
er auch so möglichkeiten oder das
objektive an dem relativen ist dass es
relativ ist das aber hier ist jetzt der
punkt der das wir jetzt genau schauen
müssen wie die gegenwart geartet ist wie
wir dieses gegenwärtigen moment genau
anschauen müssen und jetzt sagt er
folgendes denn wenn es sicher strecke
wird sie sich also das gegenwärtige
moment lässt sich dagegen im vergangenes
und zukünftiges aufspalten
das habe gegenwärtig ist hat keine
ausdehnung wo also ist eine zeit die wir
lange nennen können wenn die zukunft von
dieser aber sagen wir nicht dass sie
lange ist weil sie noch nicht da ist
weil noch nichts da ist was lang sein
kann viel sagen wir dass sie langsam
wird das hat er schon davon gesagt man
wird sie also lang sein
denn wenn sie dann immer noch zukünftig
ist wird sie nicht lang sein weil nichts
da ist das lang sein könnte ist die zeit
aber erst dann lang nachdem sie gerade
aus zukünftigen das noch nicht ist so
sein gewonnen hat und gegenwärtig
geworden ist so dass sie etwas sein kann
was lang ist dann ruft die gegenwärtige
zeit an
dass sie nicht lang sein kann
genau dazu könnte eine von der gegenwart
aus gesehen das war ja auch schon die
lösung dafür mit diesem index versehen
mit diesem die zeit dauern also wir
können eigentlich von einer zeit dauern
nur unter logisch sprechen und wir
können aber das modifizieren auf die
vergangenheit auf die zukunft beziehen
wenn wir eben das unter dem modus dem
gesichtspunkt der dimension bestimmt
nämlich auf strache
richtig also das gäbe diese möglichkeit
dass wir sagen wir müssen halt
unterscheiden
wir müssen es relativieren aber ich
denke also es ist wäre der trick wäre
der dass wir das gegenwärtige des
zukünftig und das gegenwärtige des
vergangenen antizipieren das wäre es
fast als ob betrachten als ob das
zukünftige gegenwärtig wäre als ob das
vergangene gegen wertet wäre also wir
drehen sozusagen die vergangenheit
beziehen sie imaginär auf die gegenwart
und tun so als das ist also man kann
natürlich durchaus sagen wo der punkt
ist dass nicht nur ein sprachliches
problem also es gibt ja diesen
linguistic turn in der philosophie
wittgenstein und solche neue und denker
die sagen meisten probleme die sie uns
für so viele stellen sind reine
sprachprobleme sollten einfach anders
drüber sprechen und das hat sowas davon
wieder stimmig in zonen scheint auch in
sprache ist interessant ich lese nur
noch das letzte zitat und dennoch herren
nehmen wir zeitabschnitte war
vergleichen sie miteinander und machen
manchen manche länger manche kürzer wir
messen auch in wie vielen oder kürzer
diese eine zeit ist als jene und
antworten zb diese zeit doppelt oder
dreimal zu lang
diese andere aber habe einfach ein junge
sei ebenso lang wie jene zeit
wir müssen die zeiten aber wenn sie
vorübergehend der wir sie im wahrnehmen
messen wer aber kann vergangenes messen
das nicht mehr ist oder zukünftiges das
noch nicht ist doch nur einer der so
dreist wäre zu sagen können messen was
nicht ist
man kann die zeit also wahrnehmen und
messen während sie vorüber geht sobald
sie aber vorüber gegangen ist kann man
es nicht weil sie dann ja nicht mehr ist
ein bisschen probleme weil er schreibt
dass wir als ob wir wirklich zeit messen
in dem gehalt eigentlich eine zustands
fällen
wer denkt dass natürlich das alte bild
ist halt auch dass das universum auf die
sterne zwei davon konnten geschaffen
worden sind das vielleicht anders
ausgegangen dass jahre alte instrument
derzeitiges team
im weit ist es so wenn die an dem tag
mit zehn mann mit helm
einen zustand es was wir dann da als
zeit bezeichnen das
das was wir subjektiv als überbrückung
empfinden das lied schreibt er jetzt ja
nicht auch eigentlich müssten wir
tatsächlich mahlzeit sondern es ist ein
denn ja es gibt schon die möglichkeit
zeit zum essen jetzt mit sanduhren oder
wie sie sagt mit oder zu relation ihren
sag ich mal zeit ein verhältnis zu
bringen sei nicht möglich aus gegenwart
wir müssen jetzt trotzdem irgendwie
lang in st für 29
die zeit dauert die licht braucht aber
es ist ja eigentlich immer so möchte
nach zustand bringen also wenn wir zeit
irgendwie greifbar machen aber dann ist
mir trotzdem irgendwie und sind zwei
drei dimensionen bewegen und so stand
das ist eine spannende frage auf die wir
noch näher eingehen werden jedenfalls
hier stellt sich jetzt die frage wie man
und theologischen vergangenen
zukünftigen reden soll und er sagte dass
diese modelle rede war es will ihm
agieren sie als geben und dem
gesichtspunkt des irgendwann mal
gegenwärtig science oder gegen gewesen
science also wir machen ein index dazu
wir sind jetzt nicht ganz fertig
geworden wir wollen uns die letzten tage
noch aufheben für die nächste sitzung
ich will jetzt aber noch in einem kurzen
ausblick gegen das in der nächsten
sitzung machen werden
also sie sehen wir haben hier noch
ungefähr so zehn zitate die folien habe
ich auf die app gestellt die schädlichen
auch noch mal um und den nächsten
sitzung werden wir also wenn man die
letzten sachen von augustinus lesern
gerade diese frage ausstellen der
kommilitone aufgeworfen hat wie denn
dann diese verschiedenen dimensionen die
gegenwart des zukünftigen gegenwart es
vergangen mit unserer subjektivität
zusammen die lösung wird design das
augustinus die gegenwart ist und
theologisch science mäßig verdi für
zukunft kommt die vergangenheit die sind
irgendwie wirklich und zwar nur deswegen
als in einem bezug zu unserer seele
sehnt aktivität stehen wir erhoffen
erwarten also die zukunft ist ein modus
der aktivität der seele des erwarten und
erhoffen uns des antizipieren und die
vergangenheit ist ebenso real aber nur
im modus einer seelischen subjektiven
aktivität nämlich das erinnern des
gedenkens also zeitliche dimensionen die
eigentlichen theologisch betrachtet
nicht sind weil sie ja noch nicht sind
oder nicht mehr
die werden wird sich ökologisch sinnvoll
von bedeutung und teams auf die
aktivität der seele des subjekts gezogen
werden die sich dazu verhalten kann
das ist dann die lösung dieses ganzen
problems wollte jetzt an verwickeln wir
lesen es aber im nächsten sitzung noch
mal gemeinsam und dann werden wir der
zweiten hälfte dieser sitzung auf
aristoteles zu sprechen kommen der nicht
so viel geschrieben hat aber der dieses
problem der bewegung und der veränderung
von dem sie gerade gesprochen haben sehr
sehr scharfsinnig analysiert haben und
wir wollen dass die frage versuchen zu
klären wie die zeit und bewegung
miteinander zu tun haben dann bis zur
nächsten sitzung